the first thing we want to understand is
you know what does it mean to draw an
angle in standard position well what you
want to do is you want to have your
initial ray pointing in the positive
x-axis direction so it's pointing
towards the right here and you can think
of this as a spinner like imagine if
this was like a game and you were
spinning the spinner you know it's going
to rotate either counterclockwise or
clockwise now the thing to pay attention
to when you're drawing an angle in
standard position is that if you're
going counterclockwise right this
direction CCW that's actually a positive
angle if you're going clockwise this
direction that's actually going to be a
negative angle so you want to pay
attention to that so again what we're
going to do is going to start here 210
degrees we're going to rotate 90 is here
180 is here that's a half a turn plus 30
more it's gonna put us over here at 210
degrees now what I like to do is I like
to draw an arrow just to show the
direction that I'm heading and this is
your initial ray this is your terminal a
terminal ray and that's the that's the
angle there in between so let's go
through another example let's do one in
degrees and then we'll do a couple in
radians so negative 400 degrees so again
we start here facing the positive x-axis
Direction negative angle means we're
going to go clockwise so what we're
gonna do here is we're gonna rotate 90
180 270 360 notice I'm spiraling out and
then how many more to get to 400 that's
about 40 degrees and so we're gonna end
up right there and I'm just going to
draw my arrow to show the direction that
I went so that's negative 400 okay let's
do some Radian ones now so 3 pi again we
start over here in the positive x-axis
direction and remember pi represents
what 180 degrees so you want to memorize
that pi is 180 so 3 PI this is positive
so we're gonna be heading
counterclockwise 180 that's 1 pi 360
that's 2 pi and another 180 that's
another pi that gives us 3 pi so that's
going to be our terminal ray where it
terminates or ends and we've drawn our
angle so let's go to one more example an
introductory example then we're get into
some ones that you can practice negative
7 PI over 3 so what you want to do here
is you want to face that positive x-axis
direction and what I like to do when
it's a
a improper fraction like this where the
numerator is larger than the denominator
is to write it as a mixed number so what
I mean by that is how many times is 3
going to 7 well it goes in two times
with one left over so this is really
like two and one thirds pi and you can
see it's negative so that means we're
going to be going clockwise so let's go
ahead and do that so one pi remember is
182 pi is another 180 that's 360 and
then a third of Pi now because pi is 180
that's like a half a revolution we're
gonna go a third of the way that's gonna
be about right here okay and so there's
going to be where it terminates or ends